hello and welcome to this video playing
I am van nostrand ghost hunt well you
never know ok let's see 6 line is
incredibly popular and keep keep getting
it here you know online blitz I mean I
understand that this is kind of okay but
surprising how often it is actually
played and people i mean Bishop c5 is an
uncommon move let's see now i could go
see 5 here it's an interesting or try to
yeah try to make d5 harder to play yeah
he cannot cover this pawn
at least I don't see how yeah this is an
idea trying to get the night away but I
will still just take this night at five
is a pretty pretty awful threat okay so
hmm yeah well okay night at five to six
I don't know how how much it really um
helps okay I mean I have a hard time to
believe that this shouldn't be good so
this one can just take up six maybe yeah
i just take f6 I don't think tears but I
could put the night on d6 it looks very
very funny
even I g5 could be a move but then you
will move the deep on ok I should have
just taken there a lot quicker okay and
he's got d5 coming up how to do this I
can just remove it prophylactic lie
maybe I've want to send upon so it's not
not that bad night before
maybe maybe this one to prepare deform
that's a little bit murky in this
position check I didn't see that move
coming to be honest mmm have to move the
King now hmm not nice
maybe I managed bishop mf3 and then get
this sorted
you
and I to be forced coming here
hmm I should have thought about this a
little bit could have played the Queen
instead I don't really I don't have good
square cm
again not ideal after the opponent
blunders the big big porn in the center
and then you get this position whoa not
good
I also totally overlooked every move
here wow wow yeah 93 23 I really have no
development whatsoever
am I still have some material yeah but
it looks very shaky all this
this success not so much about the porn
but I want that bloody d farm checkmate
oh yeah that's a pretty pretty fitting
end to this game Wow yeah I really have
huge problems concentrating I don't know
what's what's going on yeah I mean I'm
just winning in the opening here he
blundered the before one but I couldn't
couldn't finish it yeah the engine gives
night ed 6 and it's basically over yeah
I wasn't sure about all this I wasn't
sure about it I thought maybe like g6
coming but I've got d4 here right it's a
ridiculous position for black what
didn't I do that I always have the check
and then i can do whatever i it is
totally totally lost position from like
yeah okay this is also this also should
be good maybe I'm just playing it like a
[ __ ] and well I'm very likely doing the
dashes I should just cancel here in this
position and nothing happens right
before I can play Quincy form I was
thinking you might be able to attack the
pawn something like this but a 4 is also
hanging I can just take a form i can
also take 84 here for four simple
advantage very strange yeah and I just
over looked Bishop a five chick didn't
see the moon and that sent me into
disarray after Ruby one white is still a
lot better I mean hmm and this is
turning everything around
and ya know he plays it in a powerful
way I mean here like sure you okay to
still wince okay with the double attack
now i'm just playing like really really
badly at the moon really badly let's see
one now wins for black which you didn't
see some chicks and creation play this
after which i'm still okay but I blunder
made seven eight yeah I don't know I
really don't know what it is I'm very
rusty of course yet didn't do much but
it really looks bad really looks bad I
mean probably the only way to gain all
of this is to keep playing and it will
get better eventually it always has been
in the past I've had those slumps but it
feels bad like a really really bad slump
ok anyway thanks for watching